it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca
to run along someone uh who has a name
we all like around here how you doing
amy
hello hello i got rocky here and he's
broke i mean literally this little break
i just was rubbing his belly because he
was just loving it
he is a seven-year-old chewini he's a
little squirrely because he looks like
he wants to have his belly rubbed
but he's the sweetest little guy he does
well with other small
dogs and he would just make a really
wonderful companion
um i you know i i foresee this guy
getting adopted really quickly and he
deserves
the most loving home ever all right
chawini for those of us who are not
fully
understanding of all the different
breeds is what he is a
chihuahua dachshund mix um he's got the
long body of a dachshund
um but he's he's not a purebred
dachshund but um he's definitely
you can see the document i'm just a
little squirrely but he's
really cute he looks like a sweet dog do
we know if he's good around kids or
other animals anything like that
you know with kids we always you know
air on the side of caution just mature
kids that know how to be gentle with
dogs he's really really sweet and he
really loves to just
he's spunky he likes to get locked but
you know always with children always
supervised especially with the new dog
but he's wonderful he's gonna make a
great family member
all right you got some other cool things
going on there amy i only say that
because my
producer said something in my ear that
sounded like remember my house
so maybe you can pick up on that i i'm
not sure if i caught
house but i don't know i i can't quite
here
oh she was saying a dog for an active
house which you were saying at the same
time
oh yeah you know he's great for really
just about any household he loves just
the walks but he's kind of mellow too he
just wants it you know honestly like
this whole time he wanted his belly
rubbed
so i mean if you have an extra hand and
you just want to like give him some love
and scratches while you're watching tv
on the couch
this is your guy all right as always
people can make appointments to come
meet rocky and any of the other pets you
have up for adoption there
absolutely visit nevadaspca.org just
schedule your appointment online and
hopefully we'll find rocky a great home
soon
love it amy it's good to see you if you
are interested in adopting a pet you can
go to nevadaspca.org
or call them at
seven 702-873-7720 two at